but the question Still Remains about why
this termination happened and there have
been many reports about how it was
related to lawsuits and so on and you
know I I told you yesterday I don't buy
that I just don't buy it I have no
inside information I have no Insight I
have no sources that I'm talking to all
I have is my own BS meter that I that is
is usually pretty well honed and uh and
I don't buy it I don't buy anything to
do with lawsuits I told you yesterday
that to me this is simply this happened
because because of who Tucker is and
what he says and the stands that he
takes
um the fact that he's actually an
effective right-wing figure an advocate
that's why he's not welcome at Fox and
that's why they got rid of him and now
there's a new report from Vanity Fair
which seems to confirm this
so this is Vanity Fair it says 24 hours
after Fox News ousted its high rated
highest rated host the network has yet
to explain one of the most shocking uh
defenestrations in cable news history
I'm not gonna I'm not going to be on the
release of Fox News spokeswoman uh
texted yesterday when I asked her for
comment in this information void
multiple theories about why Fox fired
Carlson circulated the media
it was Fallout from the Dominion
settlement it was punishment for vulgar
text messages published in Dominion
court filings it was a consequence of
former Fox producer Abby grossberg's
lawsuit which we'll talk more about that
in a minute which alleged Carlson
oversaw a hostile work environment
uh but none of these potential reasons
fully add up
Fox News anchor Maria uh
Bartiromo hyped Dominion of conspiracies
far more than Carlson did and yet she
remains in on the air Fox had access to
Carlson's texts and emails and been in a
lawsuit for months and they didn't
punish him so on and so forth so that's
why all that doesn't line up mystery
remains why did Fox News take its
biggest star off the air a new theory
has emerged
according to the source
Fox corporation uh chair Rupert Murdoch
removed Carlson over remarks that
Carlson made during a speech at the
Heritage foundation's 50th anniversary
gala on Friday night Carlson laced his
speech with religious overtones that
even Murdoch found too extreme according
to the source who was briefed on
Murdoch's decision making Carlson told
the Heritage audience that National
politics has become a battle between
good and evil Carlson said that people
advocating for transgender rights and
Dei programs want to destroy America and
they could not be persuaded with facts
quote we should say that and stop
engaging with these totally fraudulent
debates I've tried that doesn't work the
answer Carlson suggested was prayer I've
concluded that it might be worth taking
just 10 minutes out of your busy
schedule to say a prayer for the future
and I hope you will
that's what he says it's a great speech
by the way
um and everything that he says in the
speech is 100 accurate this is in fact
uh a battle of good versus evil
um this has gone well beyond any sort of
debate over the facts because we we are
debating with people who don't care
about the facts they such as they don't
care about the facts they
they reject
the concept of facts
they reject in principle The Very idea
that there can be a fact okay these are
relativists everything is all truth is
relative we all get our own truth
right we all have we all live in our own
Universe we have our own truth and we
get to set the rules for our own
universe according to our our own you
know emotional and narcissistic whims
that's what they believe that's what all
this is about and it is a spiritual
battle versus good of good versus evil
tuck Carlson's 100 correct about that
and according to this report that's a
big reason why he got canned
um
quote that stuff freaks Rupert out he
doesn't like all the spiritual talk the
source said
Rupert Murdoch was perhaps unnerved by
Carlson's uh uh mess ionism because it
echoed the end times world view of
Murdoch's ex-fiancee and Leslie Smith
The Source said in a May cover story of
uh Vanity Fair uh Murdoch and Smith
called off their two-week engagement
because Smith had told people that
Carlson was a messenger from God
Murdoch had seen Carlson and Smith
discuss religion firsthand and so
apparently they were at a dinner back in
March and uh River Murdoch's then fiance
has would have been going on wife number
five I think was having this
conversation with son Carlson Rupert
Murdoch was there and they were talking
about all these things about how this is
a spiritual battle good versus evil
Rupert Murdoch was there he didn't like
that uh shortly after that he dumps the
fiance and then shortly after that he
gets rid of Tucker Carlson that's the
report anyway
this makes a lot more sense
I mean it doesn't make sense to fire him
for it but it makes sense that fox would
uh makes more sense than anything tied
to this Abby grossberg lawsuit which you
know other media Outlets are still
claiming
is one of the central reasons why he got
fired so Yahoo has this
grossberg formerly a senior booking
producer for Fox News began working as
the head of booking for Tucker Carlson
tonight last year she was fired by Fox
News last month after filing suit
against the company claiming that she
was bullied and subjected to sexist and
anti-semitic comments while working on
Carlson's show
there are other reports by the way that
she never actually met Tucker Carlson so
she was never in the same room as him
According to some reports but in a
separate lawsuit filed in Delaware
grossberg claimed that she was coerced
by the company's lawyers to give
misleading answers to her deposition of
the Dominion case in the 79-page lawsuit
filed in the southern district of New
York Roseburg said that she was startled
by the behavior of male colleagues when
she showed up for her first day of work
on Carlson's show in September according
to grossberg she arrived at the office
to see many large and blown up
photographs of Nancy Pelosi in a
plunging bath bathing suit revealing her
cleavage I think we have uh she also is
doing the rounds on MSNBC of course
another BDL that's talking about all her
horrible experiences working for Tucker
Carlson we have the clip of her talking
about this traumatic encounter with
Nancy Pelosi pictures let's watch that
I was hoping that it would be more
professional and what he was portraying
on air was just a show and unfortunately
that wasn't the case
so when do you realize that immediately
I show up first day of work and I know
that this is a popular one it's been
widely publicized there are literally
pictures like this big of Nancy Pelosi
in a bathing suit in Europe plastered
all over
um there was even one on my computer
screen for the temporary computer I had
to use and I had to take it down just to
work
um within a few days there I was called
into Justin Wells office with Alex
mccaskill who was a senior producer as
well and
if Maria was having an affair with Kevin
McCarthy
it was just I was shocked I couldn't
even believe it I was floored
foreign
companies are strong arming their
customers to support abortion canceling
customers for their political views and
making a mockery of women by supporting
transgender models no government agency
institution or company is allowed to
just be what it is and focus on
fulfilling the tasks that it was made to
fulfill a beer company can't just make
beer anymore their primary concern is
not with brewing and distributing beer
but with showing their support of the
left's political and cultural agenda but
Public Square offers a new solution
Public Square is an app and it's a
website as well where you can get
connected to tens of thousands of
businesses from all different industries
that share your value for Life family
and freedom Public Square also offers
discounts to many high quality
businesses on the platform so you can
actually have an incentive to spend
money with companies that don't hate you
whether you're looking for new athletic
clothing that knows what a woman is a
banking partner that you count on simply
a new restaurant in your area that won't
lecture you about your political views
as you're trying to enjoy a meal with
your family head over to
publicsq.com that's publicsq.com
square is free to join as a consumer or
a business owner you can get started at
publicsq.com or download their app today
that's publicsq.com
the pro-life battle has finally left DC
and is going to the Grassroots as one of
the largest pro-life organizations in
the entire world no one is in a better
position than 40 Days for life to end
abortion in a post-row America with 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities because of
that they actually have a larger
presence in Blue State specifically
California former abortion clinic
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no show rate to go as
high as 75 percent which is very
detrimental to their business which is a
very good thing these law-abiding vigils
have helped close abortion facilities in
San Francisco Seattle Chicago many other
cities as well they're also leading the
way in efforts to prevent pharmacies
from dispensing chemical abortions you
can support their work and check out
their locations podcast and free
magazine 40daysforlife.com it's really
important that you do that because if
you think that this is this issue is
over and it's all solved now because uh
row is on the ash heap of History you're
totally wrong the fight has never been
more important so for more information
on 40 Days for Life go to
40daysforlife.com
look you know what Abby you're the one
body shaming Nancy Pelosi so what maybe
they're maybe they they think that Nancy
Pelosi is a beautiful woman and uh and
and that's all right
this is your assumption so you have
decided to interpret that in a negative
way
shame on you
can you imagine if Abby grossberg came
to work for the daily wire and she
encountered our uh our our five foot
tall you know cigar store Indian of uh
of uh Elizabeth Warren
how would she I mean you should break
down in tears immediately upon
encountering that uh she also she says
that uh staff members frequently engaged
in group discussion in which
misogynistic views of women as objects
to be judged solely based on their
appearance were broadcasted
in these discussions no woman whether
she was a republican politician or
female staffer at Fox News was safe from
suddenly becoming the target of sexist
demeaning comments
in one instance cited by the paper the
lawsuit recalled a crass and sexist
discussion in The Newsroom before the
Republican gubernatorial candidate uh in
Michigan Tudor Dixon was scheduled to
appear as a guest on Carlson show before
Dixon arrived staffers discussed whether
Miss Dixon or her opponent Gretchen
Whitmer was hotter
that's an interesting question and
that's a debate many of us have had
um I think ultimately uh Tudor Dixon's
going to be the more attractive one
um gretchy Whitmer you know in my
opinion the fact that she's so
evil it's just you you can't quite maybe
it's not fair to
to deduct points based on that in the
discussion of this sort but the fact
that she is so despicably horrifically
evil I think it does exude out of her
and it actually affects her physically
as well but a very interesting
conversation
um that apparently traumatized poor uh
Abby grossberg
um
and then okay in another instance
mccaskill allegedly referred to uh a
room
in the office where Fox News employees
could pump breast milk as a waste of
space
does someone worked for Fox said that
the room for pumping breast milk is a
waste of space and suggests that it
should be converted into a room of
tanning beds for the guys to tan their
testicles
um you know if that was actually said
Abby that's what's known as we actually
have a word for that it's called a joke
so someone was making a joke is what
they were doing if that was even said at
all
but she also accuses the Tucker team of
of saying and doing a lot of things that
uh that don't pass the smell test at all
so let's let's watch one more clip here
when I got to Tucker it was different
and as a text that came out revealed my
suspicions
um he was looking for Ratings bait
purely and was also looking for power it
was a combination of ratings and power
and manipulating the audience
um and manipulating also the political
system there was an aspect of I could
pick who the house speaker is I can pick
who the president of the United States
is or who the Republican candidate's
going to be and I thought that was
really dangerous and didn't want that
kind of power I didn't want to have
Senate candidates calling me and being
very upset are you going to destroy our
whole campaign tonight because he could
do that and he would call and tell them
that that if you don't participate or
you don't come on the show we will
destroy you and I was told to tell that
to congressmen sometimes and I didn't
how can I it was disrespectful so in
addition to the misogyny and the sexism
and the anti-semitism there was also
just this sort of moral growth with me
where I reached a breaking point because
of all of those things and I literally
did not want to do it anymore it felt
disgusting I stopped watching news when
I came home I didn't watch anything I
just didn't want to because I was so
depressed and disillusioned by the
entire media system because of Tucker
Carlson oh my moral growth you know the
only look the only mistake that uh the
Tucker team made and it's not like this
is Chuck Carlson himself he doesn't he's
not overseeing every aspect that's not
the way it works but you know the only
thing obviously is hiring this woman but
of course it's just it's not always easy
to sniff these kinds of people out
uh the kind of person who's gonna see
you know a joking picture of Nancy
Pelosi if it's even true that the
pictures are frozen but see a picture
like that and be offended
just get over yourself my God how do you
function in life
that's our moral that's my moral group
and my moral growth right my moral
growth was that I could work there
and and take the paychecks and then I
get fired and only then do do I do I
turn you know I get fired and then I
turn around and try to uh the profit to
the tune of however many millions she's
suing for that's all part of the moral
growth
suing
for Millions because you were offended
by alleged jokes right that's a sign of
moral growth I will say though that I am
there is one Revelation from this that I
that really disappoints me uh as much of
a fan tuck Carlson as I am
when she said
that Tucker Carlson
was interested in ratings
good Lord I
I'm I am so disappointed
that he wanted to get ratings for his
show
that is unacceptable and surely Tucker
Carlson the only figure in all of media
that's concerned about ratings
everyone it doesn't come up you know and
I've worked in media I can tell you
right now I've never even encountered a
conversation like this no one talks
about it
performance ratings you know downloads
advertising dollars we never discuss it
in fact if I'm in a if it even on
occasion someone's about to maybe I'm in
a meeting someone broaches the
conversation well let's look at the
numbers nope we're not talking about
this doesn't matter how dare you
get out of the room
I say to Jeremy boring
that's what happens in in so Tucker
Carlson the only figure in all of media
who cares about ratings and so that is a
scandal but all the rest of it not so
much
um and the claim that she as a like a
booking producer was told to call up
congressman and say come on the show or
we'll destroy you uh that also didn't
happen that's that's not the way it
works
and this is why listen
I don't know the percentages
but it is my suspicion that the vast
majority of um
of hostile work environment claims
are really com they are they are used as
cover by losers who couldn't hack it
that's most of it
because if something illegal or actually
unethical happened then say what it was
just name it you know give actual
examples of that
but when we get these kind of broad as a
hostile work environment
um no you're just a loser and you
couldn't hack it you couldn't do it it's
a high pressure environment you know
you're working with a lot of uh you're
working with a lot of high performance
people and there's a lot of egos around
that's just the way it is in the media
business it's the way it's way that's
what it is in at high levels in any
industry that's how it is
um and uh and she couldn't deal with it
she couldn't do it
she couldn't keep up with the pressure
and so she washed out now she's filing a
lawsuit that is my
that is my interpretation that is my
theory personally about this now I'll do
it for this portion shows move over to
the members block you can become a
member today by using Code Walsh at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]